- So wait, so do you remember
the first time y'all met Jo?
- Yeah, it was a long, long time.
Here's the thing: I remember.
She doesn't remember.
- Well, first of all, shut up.
Okay. Second, I remember.
What I do remember, Kelly,
is that this very studio was where
we filmed Chelsea Lately
for like four or five years.
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
And Jo, what I do remember is
Jo was a regular on that show.
He was on my round table all the time,
'cause we had comedians
on and he was the best.
- There was no chemistry then?
There was-
- Well, he says I had a crush
on him during that time.
I also don't recall that.
(Kelly laughing)
You know?
- She doesn't recall anything.
- [Kelly] Yeah, unless
it's like selective memory?
- We met through a mutual
friend, Jon Lovitz.
- Okay, yes.
- Oh.
- And Jon Lovitz was doing
a show at the Laugh Factory.
He was like, "You have to meet Chelsea.
She's hysterical.
(Kelly laughs)
She's my only friend on MySpace."
- On MySpace!
- MySpace. So I went to MySpace,
and it was really Chelsea.
And then she started coming on the shows
and she told me about the show
that she was about to develop
and long story short,
she came up with an idea
that I was supposed to be on the show,
and then I turned it down
and then she just hated me for forever.
- He says I asked him to be my sidekick.
Remember Chewy?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He was my little nugget sidekick.
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- Well, apparently, I went to him first,
and Jo turned me down
and then I hired Chewy.
So, Yeah.
- [Jo] But she doesn't
remember any of that.
- Look, you missed out.
Y'all could have had all
this love for that long.
- Mm-hm, mm-hm.
- [Kelly] Shame on you, Jo.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah. I used to sit there,
the panel used to be right here,
she used to be right here,
and I used to look at her like this.
- Oh, I loved your show.
Oh my gosh.
- He did, he did.
He had a crush on me. I knew that.
- But I was never gonna get involved
with somebody on my round table.
You know what I mean?
Like, to me, they were just
like comic boys and I was,
it was almost like I was a
parent in that dynamic, you know?
I mean, I'm sure nobody thought of me
as their mother now, but.
- [Kelly] Do you play mommy now, or?
I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
We're gonna take that out.
- No.
- [Kelly] Sorry.
- Actually, I think we
should leave that in, Kelly.
- Keeping it daytime.